all right I I just something short to
help you all
um we already know there's like
progressions in
training um one has to allow for the
difference between when one is talking
about what is the
ideal and then what is the actual
learning curves you're dealing with
okay and I think anybody who understands
any kind of training knows that there's
a difference there is where we should be
and then the reality of where we are
okay and they don't contradict each
other they're just different
perspectives so I want to give you
something um short and sweet um um
because some of you are too ill to to
ever get to the ideal and so you need
some helpful things to maybe one day you
have a breakthrough
okay there's too much tension there too
much stress there's too much what what I
call
agitation and my definition of agitation
is your your body mind is is is being
forced to function with within an
environment that is uh overriding its
capacity so for in everyday speak you
know that would include anxiety
depression that would include digestive
problems immune
disorders um uh [\h__\h] up
relationships uh all that kind of stuff
okay just not
well you're suffering sometimes very
severely you're suicidal sometimes
you're just got a stomach ache and
diarrhea okay maybe some hair is falling
out in the shower maybe you didn't sleep
well okay maybe
you're you're
lonely okay this that's all what I call
agitation or over
agitation so something to help you with
that because training at the ideal level
is going to assume that you're not over
agitated you just can't do it it's not
possible but as a learning curve we come
to training
with
agitation
okay it's no different than training
requires a certain level of mobility and
a certain level of strength so um we're
going to have to lift weights cuz you're
a weak
stiffy right we have to do we have to do
that we have to in a way prepare
ourselves to one day train and the
biggest mistake is we don't think we
have to we think we're
training because we're lifting weights
we're not you're just you're weak it's
why we're lifting
weights like in the last tech in the
techniques we did today there's a
certain level of suppleness and a
certain level of strength that's just
assumed even in the reconciliation of
Yin and
Yang you you have to have a certain
level of strength and uh some of you
don't have it and there's no way you're
going to pick this person up to balance
them on your chest there's just no way
okay so we have to do things get you
there well the same way
spiritually to reconcile the ego
tripartite
mind we have to be in a certain achieved
level of spirituality to get there and
it cannot entail
agitation agitation like muscle
weakness we're going to have to work on
that first this this is where we're
going now
okay um I'll remind you though that this
is at best a
Sal some sort of tonic or something you
put on a on a wound and try
to you know in a way make sure you don't
[\h__\h] kill
yourself when it gets that far make sure
you
don't have an irreversible health
condition cuz you took it that far do
you see in those in those senses a salv
is pretty
important but it is nothing but
that
meaning you [\h__\h] up here something
hopefully you can unfuck this before
it's
irreversible get it it's it's important
it's it's like I tell the recruit
recruits in law
enforcement you know you [\h__\h] up in your
Patrol strategy that's why you're having
to do this here's something that'll work
and even as I tell them that I told them
this I said it I'll get myself out of it
but in my head I'm telling myself you
[\h__\h] have this coming because you
[\h__\h] up so as you have a salve I don't
want you to think of it as a cure all
because moderns think
of medicines as cure alls when they're
not they're just masking
symptoms your body heals
itself you have to have a body that can
heal you take an
aspirin it it'll cut the edge off of the
headache or an Advil you see of the
headache but you have you having to keep
taking them you keep having headaches
something is [\h__\h] up with you and you
need to fix
that you can't go I have adill so I
don't have to fix what's [\h__\h] up with
me that's not true so I'm hesitant and
and why it's it's those that have been
here it's been decades you've been here
I haven't shown you this stuff I've
shown you the other stuff how to unfuck
yourself but the problem is as a
teacher decades have gone by and you
haven't learned how to unfuck
yourself that's Decades of agitation
that's that's going to be hard to
reverse
now then we have people though in the
patreon community they haven't done any
of the base work they've already lived
for decades with agitation they need a
solve
too
okay that's what this is don't make it a
cure
all it it's like Crisis
management like break glass in case of
emergency you should be doing the
Bedrock practices and the four
disciplines so you don't ever need
this and and and it is contained within
all of your
iido so just coming to the dojo obeying
the Bedrock practice of those 4 to 6
hours per day you you're doing it so you
shouldn't have but we don't do that do
we so we have to touch base on those
Bedrock practices we have to touch base
on the four disciplines and you have to
stop ignoring them because eventually
just like you lived an effed up enough
life now you have migraines and there's
no every medication's not is not working
and even if it is working you're still
laying in bed all night and with the
rest of your life going to [\h__\h] is that
working I don't think
so let me explain the cosmology SL
energetics of what is going on in
agitation
at the East End of the Silk
Road there's very much a young a yinong
theory at things uh especially later in
history but as you go back it's very
similar to the West End and the West
End and older in history on the East End
is basically you are in opposition to
God you are resisting God and know the
West understand the conventional wisdom
is one cannot resist the will of
God in the old east end this Heaven has
a will Heaven is uh is equivalent to the
god concept and there is a Heaven's
way and woe to he or she who [\h__\h] up
with that way same exact thing as you go
more recent but we were talking
centuries
ago basically Heaven's will God's will
Heaven
Chi that is blocked is not doing or
allowed to do what it needs to do or
what it is to do is now
toxic
energetically what happens to our body
mind is
[Music]
our Mis applying of the four disciplines
and our
ignorance or our ignoring sorry our
ignoring of the Bedrock
practices we
create blockage in our body that starts
to accumulate Heaven chi in the top part
of our body
mind
so event and these are ancient systems
of the body so even for example if my
heart is in my upper thoracic cavity
your heart is connected to your kidney
system it's part of that and so you you
have you have to expand what you what
what I mean by your upper body it's not
so upper
okay but this is how you will get
eventually your autoimmune disorders
which nobody's recognizing anymore it's
I it's hard to find someone that doesn't
have an autoimmune disorder nowadays or
and or a digestive disorder of one kind
or another it's like
normal in the in the same way as we
see anxiety and depression is like it's
hard to find someone like that doesn't
have it nowadays okay and it gets worse
and worse okay because our not doing the
four disciplines not doing the Bedrock
practices we create these Yin blockages
in our body and the heaven Chi is now
blocked and it becomes
toxic so you have to do you have to uh
live a way that does not block the
heaven shei and it can do what it needs
to do what is that
descend okay it must
descend
cannot stay still it must descend and it
must
convert it it is the the order of
it
so God must the Thunder God must kiss
the mother
earth in mythological terms and you're
keeping them
apart and now he's pissed
so we're going to do some
stuff that you should try to do whenever
you feel agitated and I gave you the
symptomology for that okay your
scattered brain too is in there um your
memory issues your vision all kinds of
stuff
okay um your Mobility your
suppleness uh your trigger ability all
that is all this okay all right so we
have to bring down this Yi we have to in
a way as an analogy you have to break
the dam you have uh so that it can flow
the water can flow okay all right so
let's uh stand
up and as I said you do this in every
single iido
technique just what you do okay so in
the first class and the ne was a class
you were doing you had to have done it
to get the guy up to your chest there's
just absolutely no way as you could see
we had people that had no chance of
getting that person up to the chest
versus those that could get up get that
mass up to the chest it was effortless
right it was effortless oh but to others
seemed impossible okay all right so
basically you start with the standing
drill of the I and C you set okay so get
your
feet under your
hips shift your
weight to your midfoot vector on the
midfoot
okay and first you have to release the
tension now some can't do this standing
they just
can't and so we have the laying down
corpse pose but that is is just a drill
that you can release muscle tension
on that it does not work as well for
allowing the heaven aspect to lower do
you get that because it lowers down your
spine it does not lower perpendicular to
the Earth so when you're laying
down it's harder to allow for gravity
and the natural center of gravity to
pull or tug on this Heaven Chi or this
Heaven aspect okay but you might I'm
just so tense okay lay down and work on
releasing muscle tension okay and that
is assumed in this skill so I start to
drop if we remember these
drills okay I start scanning first for
all my
tension as I'm doing this I should feel
my shoulders
drop I should feel my throat
release I should feel this sternum
drop once I feel it
drop I'm going to start putting my
shoulders my
elbows and my
hands at the at the midfoot so I'm
vectoring that weight of those things
okay it's no different than his push
that he's pushing here I'm going to let
it drop okay this this is a young aspect
do you see and I'm going to make it drop
all right I am letting the gravitational
pull of my
Mass is a young aspect and I am going to
feel as I felt his push on my midfoot
Vector I'm going to feel the weight of
my shoulders my
elbows and my
hands on the
midfoot that young aspect is being
midfoot Vector okay as I get to there
I'm going to open L gong so I'm going to
form that little cup in my
palm you should feel some charge along
the middle
finger
okay
drop everything you can close your eyes
if you
want feel my elbow my shoulder weight
and my
hands on that midfoot and once I feel
the weight of those
things I should start to
feel like thickness thick air around my
hands tingling a CH charge
like okay and I ignore that and I keep
releasing muscle
tension all the way through my
body Never Letting Go of any of the
elements that I just gave
you okay now
because the chi fall follows the
mudra I'm going to use my hands okay and
I'm going to repeat the repetitions of
dropping it of letting the heaven aspect
descend through my body okay so I'm
going to turn my hands up and I to bring
the energy the T aspect up inward
spiral down from
The Middle tand
and I let it
drop till I come back to waiting my feet
hands elbow I'm sorry my hands elbow and
shoulders on my mid fooot then I do it
again our
spiral up you should feel that L gong
get
activated the inward
spiral middle
tanden start to Exhale exhale
now start to feel your weight of your
shoulders elbows and hands on your feet
let it
settle okay now I add my raising of my
whole center of gravity so I come up I
straighten my
knees
inhaling exhaling dropping my knees back
to that wui
stance
exhaling inhaling
up in through the
nose out through the
mouth
and you you repeat that repeat it and
what you're doing is a rep of drop drop
the Chek drop the Chek
which you do right away he he grabs I
drop I drop it okay right away he he uh
grabs up high whatever same thing you
feel it we're we're we're stuck on that
same thing okay my young aspect his
young aspect P
drops as I ground Vector that's what
happens okay and I have to learn how to
drop the chi aspects not just my weight
but in the beginning we tell you ground
Vector bend your knees lower your center
right well we're now using those to help
us get things to go down got it get
things to go down so if you're doing
your Bedrock
practices you should do that especially
if you've been blocking CH CU you're not
doing your Bedrock practices or you're
not doing your four disciplines or like
you're you go okay I'm going to do my
I'm start bringing in meditation or
prayer into into my daily life you
probably should do this before you you
should not just drop down on the cushion
or drop down on your knees it's not
going to work okay so you have to first
get this stuff down or you've been
living in the world the whole time and
you come to the dojo yeah you're G to
get effed up in here so you should
probably do th this exercise
was just find a corner somewhere and do
it so you're ready to train okay
definitely on Saturday when we have
zazen I wouldn't I wouldn't get on that
cushion without doing this okay uh for
some reason you guys just blow Friday or
whatever or that or you blew Monday
through Friday and you're just wrecked
by Saturday okay you could do this if
you're out there and you're working on
your let too stiff and you think you're
going to stretch your way out of it I
would say no
uh you're going to have to address the
Mind aspects of that stiffness and this
is how you address the Mind aspect of
that stiffness so you should be doing
this Dr I'm not going to sit here and
film me doing this stuff that's not
really important and as boring as hell
but the mechanics are there okay how
long should you do it for uh you should
do it till you can feel that oh I don't
I don't have that agitation anymore okay
you're like if you're doing it right it
doesn't take long
as it doesn't take long as I said you
won't need to do that Sal because you
come to the doo every day and every day
you drop this the heaven aspect every
single time this person touches you in
that immediacy so there's no reason to
do this for forever unless we're
agitated because we're not doing the
four disciplines and the Bedrock
practices okay got it and sometimes it
happens sometimes it happens okay any
questions from those that are
here thank you